My name is Samantha Kallis, and I'm a visual development artist.
A visual development artist will design anything from characters, props,...
...textures, background paintings,...
...pretty much anything that shows up on screen, somebody designed.
Today, I chose the theme of adventure.
I chose adventure because to me it's important to live your life adventurously...
...but also be adventurous in your art.
As an artist, if you're not adventurous and you don't take chances,...
...then you end up just drawing the same, old, tired thing that you're comfortable with,...
...then you never do anything new.
You never grow.
I guess the big adventure for me in the last couple of months...
...has been getting to work at Sony and working at Nickelodeon...
...and actually getting my hands dirty with animated television shows and features.
Learning from professionals who I really admire,...
...that's been the big adventure for me.